welcome back to new rockstars i'm
whitney van laningham and holy nine
hells we're getting a dnd movie as a
tabaxi arcane trickster myself i can't
wait to see my favorite tabletop rpg
coming to the silver screen you hear
that popular kids from my high school
dungeons and dragons is hot now written
and directed by jonathan goldstein and
jon francis daily aka the writing duo
behind spider-man homecoming this movie
is definitely something that i think
y'all will enjoy even if you're not a d
d super fan yet today i'm taking you
frame by frame through the new dungeons
and dragons honor among thieves trailer
point out all the d in details you might
have missed the trailer opens on
neverwinter a bustling city of craftsmen
merchants and gardeners in northwest
faerun also known as the jewel of the
north front and center you can see
castle never home of neverwinter's
rulers interestingly the movie has added
a coliseum to its landscape a structure
that doesn't exist on any official maps
of neverwinter chris pine a human bard
named edgin introduces their party as a
team of thieves made up of michelle
rodriguez a barbarian named holga
justice smith a half elf sorcerer named
simon and sophia lillis a tiefling druid
named doric peep that white dragon
statue as the party walks through the
market square it actually comes to life
later on in the trailer in the
background of this scene you can see
neverwinter's blue banner emblazoned
with three snowflakes next the party
makes their way through the underdark
expansive network of caverns tunnels and
passageways that lie underground the
city they make their way through looks
to be crackle stuff also known as the
city of blades a subterranean fire lit
home to an underground race of dwarves
called the duergar these grave dwarves
are known to be cynical and tyrannical
and are only happy when they cause the
suffering of others the statues we see
aligning the chamber are during our
priests who display psionic powers in
some d lore reggie gene page's paladin
named zenk pulls a golden helmet out of
an intricate puzzle contraption it was
revealed in an exclusive sdcc clip that
this item is called the helm of
destruction the mechanical contraption
that holds it is covered in death rooms
that likely detail how to open it in
dwarvish language the dragon we see
attacking the battlefield is a black
dragon the most brutally destructive and
solitary of all chromatic dragons these
guys are known for their ambush style
combat and their use of acid breath
which might be the gross deadly barf
coming out of the dragon's face hole as
edgan ushers his fellow adventurers to
safety you can see that he's wearing a
harper pool signifying his former
membership to a semi-secret organization
of people whose mission is to preserve
art minimize the destruction of animal
and plant life fight villainy and
protect the freedoms of those around
them the harpers mainly operate out of
northern faerun confirming that this d d
story takes place within the forgotten
realm setting the door he leads them
through also has the same symbol
inscribed on it so perhaps this is a
harper safehouse of some kind although
several important deities in d d lore
support the harpers they also have
equally powerful enemies such as the red
wizards of fey one of whom we see here
holding a glowing red horn the red
wizards of they are a magical cult of
demonologists dedicated to creating a
world of un-death filled with
spiritually reanimated corpses i think
that this artifact could possibly be the
drachorn the horn of a red dragon gifted
to dragonkind by tiamat the evil
five-headed dragon goddess as the queen
of all chromatic dragons she created the
drac horn as a means to call any
chromatic dragon within two thousand
miles however like i said the red
wizards of they are super into
necromancy so this could be a tool
unique to this movie that falls more in
line with those characters zombie
hobbies interestingly though there have
been plots by red wizards to turn living
dragons into dracoliches so that they
can command hordes of dragon zombies so
maybe the horn is being used in honor
among thieves for a little bit of both
behind the red horn is an alchemy jug a
magic container that produces any liquid
you desire i use mine for teriyaki sauce
the red wizard using the horn in the
next shot is likely sastam an incredibly
powerful lich and one of the eight
zulkers aka powerful rulers of thing he
was the ruler of necromancy and leader
of a massive army of undead soldiers i
wouldn't be surprised if this dude was
the greatest evil ever known that edgin
and his crew unleashed it seems that his
followers are blocking these civilians
escape using spell wall of force next we
get our first look at paddington 2's
very own hugh grant grant's character is
a sneaky rogue named forge fitzwilliams
who like this red wizard appears to be
on the party's side at this point in the
movie the red wizard here is likely
casting the spell slow the woods we see
here could possibly be the outer rim of
the dread ring in neverwinter wood
forged by liches dread rings or
necromantic ritual sights slash
fortresses for the red wizards of fae
the space surrounding a dread ring oozes
with evil be it through a swamp of blood
or a dusting of ash this evil aura may
be what gives the trees in this trailer
their lovely crimson hue also say hello
to this giant spider the wintry town
where edgin and holga agree to talk over
a drink is most likely located in
icewinddale home to tough pioneers and
barbarians in the northernmost region of
faerun on a snowy tundra based on the
trees i'd say that this is the town of
lonely wood surrounded by the lonely
wood forest when we see them handcuffed
a few moments later they could be at
revel's end the cliffside prison near
lonelywood this cracked snow-covered
landscape is the spine of the world the
mountain range that stretches across
northern faerun while holga forges what
looks like a home-brewed magma axe zenk
wields a dagger sword a magical weapon
exclusive to this movie simon uses the
helmet of destruction while casting
thunder waves a spell that sweeps a wave
of thunderous force out from under you
the glowing orb we see hovering in the
next shot could be a drift globe a
floating light that can either glow as
dim as a flashlight or as bright as
daylight depending on what the user
needs it for when we finally meet doric
she uses wild shape to transform from a
horse into an owl bear which looks cool
as [ __ ] but it's technically inaccurate
not to be a well actually but according
to 5e rules druids can't become angle
bears using wild shape likewise the
spell she uses a few moments later to
travel between worlds is called
dimension door which druids typically
don't have access to so doric is either
a brand new subclass or the director
master is down with the rule of cool
it's like a dungeon master but he
directs the movie as simon confirms the
creature's identity check out his
satchel it looks to me like it could be
the bag of holding a small sack that
opens to extra dimensional space
allowing its user to carry up to 500
pounds the volcanic mountain in the next
shot is mount houghton now a volcano in
the crags mountain range deep in the
neverwinter woods next we meet some cool
characters with some cool spells jason
wong's character drallis casts the
cantrip green flame blade daisy heads
red wizard casts a lightning bolt
emitting blue electric energy outside
the coliseum simon casts the protection
spell globe of invulnerability which
protects you up to a 10 foot radius
inside the coliseum our heroic gang of
thieves prepare for battle we get a much
better look at forge fitzwilliams here
in the maze holga approaches one of the
most classic and signature d d monsters
the mimic this monster shape-shifts into
normal household objects or enticing
chests of gold to attract unsuspecting
prey edgin simon and doric narrowly
dodge an attacking displacer beast by
diving headfirst into a gelatinous cube
displacer beasts are magical
panther-like creatures with six legs and
tentacles sprouting from their shoulders
their magic can bend light making
themselves displace aka appear closer or
farther away than they actually are but
diving head first into a gelatinous cube
ain't no walk in winterfell either these
suckers are acidic and typically absorb
and dissolve their prey extremely
quickly see that skeleton guy down there
that guy stayed in there a little too
long simon casts ice knife in the battle
arena a spell that flings a shard of ice
that explodes on impact whether you hit
your target or miss i've seen some fans
speculating that these projectiles could
also be magic missiles but those never
miss their intended target these blasts
don't seem as precise as magic missiles
should be but who knows like i said
earlier the rule of cool seems to apply
to a lot of scenarios in this movie
daisy head's red wizard uses misty step
to dodge the owl bear a spell that
creates a plume of mist around its
caster allowing them to teleport up to
30 feet to an unoccupied space the mist
is usually silver and not red but i
actually like that they're using an
alternate color here to display her they
powers the best part of this trailer
however is when we meet thember chowd
the chunkiest tubbiest red dragon in d d
lore his job is to protect the dory
guard of grackle stug in the underdark
and look i know that he's a chaotic evil
and that he barbecues and eats anyone
who disagrees with him but look at that
cute chubby little bunny oh love him
even if he's a bad guy he's like a thick
dangerous pug the reason why this guy
has a low belly is because he powers
grackle stugs forges with his flame
breath and in return the duraguard feed
him whatever he wants and bring him
treasure as you can see here he's trying
to eat chris pine because chris pine is
a goddamn snack finally we get to see
what we really all came here for a bard
strumming his loot and doing a jaunty
little jig but listen up doric edgin is
way more powerful than he looks the bard
in my campaign has saved our asses with
music more times than i've slayed a
monster with my custom gnomish
engineered dagger claws these are just
some of the easter eggs that i found in
the honor among thieves trailer but i
want my fellow dnd nerds to let me know
what i missed in the comments but d
indeed there's always new lore to learn
follow me on instagram and twitter
whitney puppy follow new rockstar
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you